[Musica]
da dove cominciare questa è la domanda
che mi sono posto quando un mese fa non
è arrivata una telefonata da una persona
molto cara che non vedevo sentivo da
tanti anni
romain domi di venire qui a parlare di
un tema che non solo il tema il mio
principale interesse personale ma è
anche il soggetto del mio impegno
professionale
giusto due parole per dire perché ho
visto che sul catalogo diplomatica la
cultura sembra un termine un po un po
oscuro quindi in realtà io lavoro per la
commissione europea per il servizio
esterno della commissione europea e
quindi mi occupo di greco relazioni
internazionali passato la mia vita nelle
delegazioni stern rappresentare non
europea a gestire rapporti coi paesi
soprattutto paesi del di sviluppo
occupandomi di sviluppo
una delle cose fondamentali che abbiamo
visto negli ultimi anni nonostante le
buone intenzioni che sia a livello delle
organizzazioni internazionali che a
livello dei governi che lo verso
dell'era ng
molti di questi progetti di cooperazione
internazionale
molti di sviluppo non hanno avuto i
risultati che ci si aspettava perché
perché la dimensione culturale non è mai
stata presa in considerazione
attualmente il mio mio lavoro in effetti
è questo cercare di introdurre la
dimensione culturale nei nostri rapporti
con gli altri paesi che hanno che sono
nostri partner all'interno dei progetti
di sviluppo
questa dimensione culturale cosa cosa
aggiungere
aggiungeremo fondamentale abbiamo già
sentito i vari altri speaker cosa hanno
detto oggi della della cultura della
cultura abbiamo mille definizione la mia
definizione è una definizione personale
ce ne sono mille possiamo darle tutte
penso che sia importante darvela prima
di continuare lo script la mia dignità
mia definizione è che penso che la
cultura sia una lente attraverso la
lente fondamentale attraverso il quale
noi guardiamo il mondo
guardiamo il mondo e guardiamo gli altri
e guardiamo gli altri come essere
individuali o essere all'interno di
gruppi questa lente deve essere a fuoco
se non è a fuoco se non è nitida se
opaca
abbiamo dei problemi siamo confusi non
riusciamo abbiamo timore abbiamo paura
non riusciamo a
veramente a sviluppare il nostro
potenziale
cosa ci ha aiutato a sintonizzare a
tenere questa lente a fuoco sono due
sintonizzatori fondamentali e l'identità
e la creatività questa interazione da
questi due elementi danno alla nostra
capacità di interpretare e di
rappresentare capacità di
interpretazione dell'uomo e di
rappresentare la cosa fondamentale della
cultura quello che ci distingue un po
dalle altre razze animali
quindi questo è un po quello che
cerchiamo di fare è sorpresa di questa
telefonata a sorpresa perché pensavo che
mi prendessero in giro perchè in questo
momento sto organizzando un convegno a
bruxelles che si chiama esattamente
calcio ford fusion cultura per il futuro
il romanista e nessuno lo sa in realtà
perché a giugno ancora non abbiamo
promosso invece è vero e venendo qui
sono rientrato ieri io vivo a bruxelles
in italia e mi sono accorto che c'è una
correlazione quasi inaspettata tra
quello che si dibatte da anni fra tra
ouagadougou e bruxelles tra kabul e
parigi
lo stesso dialogo sta avvenendo oggi che
a reggio emilia la cavallerizza quindi
neanche spinto un po riprendere un po i
miei i miei legami con la mia città
d'origine della marco da da molti anni
vincita ancora di più essere qua ieri
mattina uscendo dalla dell'aereo aperto
per le della sera ho visto un leggendo
così distrattamente un'intervista di un
cantante che non conosco molto se non
che è di origine albanese e alle feste
di sanremo l'anno scorso ermal meta e vi
leggo la risposta che ha dato a una
domanda tipica dei giornalisti italiani
in questo momento gli italiani sono
razzisti e lui ha detto non pieno
parlerei di lassismo ma di paura
disperazione sociale e il vuoto
culturale portano chi ha paura del
futuro a prendersela con l'altro ho
trovato questa risposta molto bella non
so se sia un bravo cantante ma
sicuramente è quello condiviso al cento
per cento quello che ha detto vuoto
culturale
in realtà vedo che c'è un interesse
molto molto interessante in tutto il
mondo
il riconoscimento finalmente che la
cultura non è andata la stessa velocità
dello sviluppo tecnologico digitale
della rivoluzione digitale e quindi
abbiamo dei problemi a interpretare e
rappresentare quello che succede intorno
io penso che la biblioteca è un luogo un
concetto che può aiutarci accelerare
questo questo questo ritmo eri
riprendere la messa a fuoco della lente
recuperare il ritardo che abbiamo
accumulato soprattutto in questo periodo
dove possiamo parlare di una certa
assenza della politica un rallentamento
dell'economia non in sicurezza che
aumenta
questo per loro la cultura può e deve
dare delle risposte importanti e penso
che aveva messi di più di più artisti
con le città
michelangelo pistoletto che vedrà domani
fra l'altro che posso concetto del terzo
paradiso della democrazia sta facendo la
rivelazione nella sua comunità e non
solo ma cuba in indonesia in africa
proponendo stimolando le persone a
pensarsi a riflettere rispetto alla
propria identità ea partecipare ognuno
nella piccola nel piccolo cerchio che
intorno al che intorno a lui e quindi
vorrei parlare di una esperienza
personale nel senso che io la mia vita è
fatta di traslochi ha vissuto in
tantissime città di galatina africa asia
medioriente e questo ho voluto dire
sempre portarsi dietro un container
traslocare eri riarredare una cosa che
non è mai mancata è stata la mia
biblioteca la biblioteca di cui vedete
forse qualche foto di qualche scaffale
nella mia biblioteca quindi la parte
fisica gli scaffali il self ma anche i
libri e soprattutto macura un po fosse
maniacale di come posizionare ai libri e
degli oggetti che ne fanno parte
questa è una cosa che mi da una
continuità perché ci sono alcuni
scaffali che sono costanti ma mi danno
proprio dall'idea di essere creativo
a muovere quindi ci sono alcuni che
dalle fatiche invece muovono rispetto
agli incontri fatti alle novità che uno
assorbito che vorrebbe assorbire perché
poi non abbiamo il tempo di leggere
tutti i libri che abbiamo una biblioteca
questa biblioteca essendo posizionata
nel soggiorno della mia casa è
ovviamente esposta anche al ai vari
visitatori a vari ospiti amici che che
ospito per una cena per un dopo cena
e questo inevitabilmente l'occhio va
sulla biblioteca e quindi da lì partono
conversazioni interessanti partono cose
che poi possono anche avere un seguito e
quindi è un po un luogo un angolo di
crescita e di sviluppo
quello che noi pensiamo normalmente
pensiamo quando parliamo di biblioteca
parliamo di biblioteca pubblica
parliamo di quel luogo dove la mia
generazione soprattutto ma che la metà
ha passato un grande tempo abbastanza
importante sia per motivi scolastici per
studiare per andare a cercare un libro
da leggere per fare ricerca per magari
sta incontrarsi con amici trovare la
ragazza che ha gli stessi gusti
non so se lo stesso lo stesso rapporto è
ancora vivo per questo quando ha avuto
questa telefonata mi sono preso un po la
così tolto la voglio andare a vedere a
bruxelles un paio di biblioteche vedere
chi è che partecipava da effettivamente
ho visto che dirti che non sono vuote
però però non molti molti studenti che
studiano un luogo di pace e qualche
anziano che invece cerca qualche libro
però manca mi sembra manca tutto una
fetta che è un po la sua fede di chi
lavora
bella e questo penso e anche dato dal
fatto della rivoluzione digitale il
fatto che non possiamo cercare qualsiasi
testo nel computer uno addirittura nel
nostro piccolo schermo del telefonino e
tante librerie come abbiamo sentito a
aprono vendono libri interessanti
ho visto reggio emilia un fiorire di
librerie di seconda mano cosa molto
interessante molto bella e quindi un po
il ruolo della biblioteca come lending
play solo scusate che ogni tanto mi
vengono qui più in termini non italiano
che quelli italiani ma un segnale che
devo passare più tempo qua e quindi mi è
venuta un'idea venuta un'idea come può
affezionare un po di più le persone
riprendere questo ruolo della biblioteca
come stimolo come acceleratore di questa
messa a fuoco di questa lente che
abbiamo comprato la mia vita in questo
momento non vedo niente nel concetto un
po di te mi sembra che sia opportuno è
giustificato tradirò una piccola
proposta alle due bibliotecari che chi
vedrà questo questo filmato e che si
interessa biblioteche perché non
lanciare un progetto in cui si invita in
si invitano i singoli cittadini a
portare la propria biblioteca
all'interno della biblioteca pubblica
per una settimana per un week end per
per un periodo e poterlo installare la
propria biblioteca e poter parlare
potesse disponibile a discuterne a fare
incontri a da generare nuove idee
questo mi sembra che corrisponde un po
anche al luogo un po di stimolo della
della biblioteca e vorrei fare questa
questa proposta di lanciare il progetto
la mia biblioteca
e per il mio scaffale potremmo dire e
quindi proposta fatta messaggio
trasmesso finito grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]